all right come on down this way oh
yeah let's get out of the way
yep
thank you
[Music]
many people ask me
what was it like that day
man pulse towel one full unit
evacuate the building
the man
and i think what they're asking is
what was it like
to be part of history
[Music]
and then
i tell them my story
and i tell them
that there were signs of devastation
everywhere
[Music]
but there are also
signs of hope
and at this extraordinary time in
history
those little
moments of caring for another
were the difference between life
[Music]
and death
it's two minutes before the time of the
hour
ap network news good morning i'm ross
simpson air jordan is apparently ready
for takeoff former nba superstar michael
jordan is on his way back to the nba
president bush is going to get an earful
from republican members of congress when
he hosts the annual congressional
barbecue tonight at the white house the
president visits a school today to tout
his education proposals before heading
back to washington
laura bush travels
i woke up at
six o'clock to the ringing of a phone
the meeting that i was supposed to
attend
was moved from
the marriott midtown
to
the marriott of world trade
this meeting was very important
and i shared a lot of the details with
ruth
my sister
and she said
ron
you know
stand out
and i said look i have a new suit and a
nice bright yellow tie
and ruth
thought that was perfect for this this
meeting
and taking the furrier cross in the
morning
walking through where the boats are
there was a man
with a glass of champagne
you know cheering people
and he passed a comment that i had a
good suit on
you know he said that's a good suit
so i felt very confident that things
look good
not a cloud in the sky
let's get this meeting over
i worked at the hotel
that was between the two towers
and i was a production show
[Music]
the greenhouse restaurant
at the back of the hotel
was all glass so when you look up you
had the two towers going up and when you
looked out you had the courtyard
[Music]
the first time i saw him i was going in
for an interview
it was like love at first sight
they're massive
and they go literally into the sky
and i remember thinking to myself
this is where i want to be
american eleven climbing table level
three five zero
american 11
boston
he will not respond to me
looks like he's turning right
[Music]
i was a battalion chief in the first
[Applause]
and battalion responsibility was for the
tip of manhattan
i'm the first one in my family to be a
firefighter my my father was a letter
carrier in the post office
and after i became a firefighter a
number of years later my my brother
joined the fire department too
kevin was three years younger than me
so it was always this looking up to the
older brother
you know sibling
um
i'm following you in your footsteps and
and every now and then i'll do you
it allowed me to step back a little bit
and yet at the same time to be connected
to our firefighters
it's an s5 box it's pretty cool i don't
think it goes into
these babies are all locked up we have
to start forcing things
that morning i had 20 years
and six days in the fire department
in other words i could have retired six
days earlier because i had my 20 years
in
but i was enjoying being in the fire
department so much that i didn't even
think about retiring
all right
and then we get a
call
for a gas leak
on the corner of church street and list
bernard
is
that day i was working as the aid to
chief viper
and that was a position that i had
only done like once or twice
several manhole covers that have blown
being a battalion aid is a very
important
job but i was always a truck guy i love
being in the truck because you get to
break down doors break windows
it was like
being a big kid listen we were never
looking forward to people's houses
burning down that wasn't it
but
you did look forward to going to fires
you know it was your job it's what you
were paid to do and and the the the
feeling you got
was very intense and while it was going
on definitely i've been in a lot of
scary situations but when it was done
you couldn't wait for the next one
[Music]
yes
okay my name is ong
i'm number three on flight 11.
okay
there's so many staff in business class
and we can't breathe in business class
so we've
i'm sitting in the back somebody's
coming back from business if you can
hold on for one second
nobody knows who's back to nr5 has
[Music]
i think the guys are up there
when i got to the marriott
i was early
i mounted the steps that led up to the
hotel
people were generally just fussing about
walking about
and just preparing for their day
[Music]
first thing i wanted to do was go to the
bathroom
check my
hair check my tie make sure i look good
for this meeting
so when i came back out still a time to
spare
i walked around the lobby of world trade
center
always in awe of the tree of life
windows
and then i walked back and sat down on
the hotel lobby
i go into work
it was already open
for breakfast
a very very busy day because we had like
two parties that day
okay we've got a pepper mill please
it's a cooked pasta in the sauces
for the banquet parties
and i was stacking it
i'm in the walk-in refrigerator
door is closed i guess it's like like a
sealant like you really can't hear
what's going on outside
there could be people right outside the
refrigerator talking i can't hear a
thing
[Music]
right here
nothing going on
[Music]
oh
it was just a huge explosion
[Music]
world trade
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
look
have the third alarm assignment going
into that area
[Music]
i remember sitting in the car
with sirens blaring
air horns from the engines and the
trucks
and lights on
i remember saying to myself
let me slow down my thinking
realizing i was going to the
largest fire of my life
and initially
i was going to be in command
[Music]
as we pull onto the west side highway
and i look up
it was overwhelming
i could see that the whole the plane
went directly through the building
and i see that there's
gaping holes in tau one
so
the ride seemed like an eternity you
know
my mind was racing
it was an extremely frightening feeling
it really was
[Music]
we pulled up right in front of the north
tower
and there was
a lot of broken glass
[Music]
i got out of the car
i put on my gear
and i walked into the lobby
and as i walked in i saw two people
to my right
badly burnt
[Applause]
[Music]
hit the top
my instinct was to help them
but i knew that was my job
my job was to take command
and i knew we had firefighters would
come in and take care of them
[Music]
as we walked in
we found out that all the jet fuel went
down the elevator shafts and blew out
the whole
lobby
so anybody standing in the path of that
blast was dead you know i
maybe 20 30 people i just seen
you know basically burnt to death on the
floor
[Music]
it was pretty horrific
occ
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
how are you doing the supply department
hi
i'm on the 100th floor of the world
trade center with 30 people in the
northeast corner
it's hard to talk
yeah
it's a lot of smoke
we're all overreacting
please come right now
all right no problem we'll get to you
please immediately
they're on the way
[Music]
yes
uh
[Music]
people were running around
and i start to smell
kerosene
from the hotel lobby
so i walked over to the revolving doors
and i looked out
[Music]
i couldn't figure out what was happening
and i saw this woman coming through the
haze
with her hands out
and i just couldn't figure out for the
life of me like what was wrong with her
and as i went closer to her and as she
walked to me i could see she was badly
burnt
and i could see that
she was still smoldering
so i brought her into the lobby
and i sat her down by the wall
[Music]
she said she couldn't see
and uh
that there was a ball of flame
and her eyes were were like pretty much
burnt shot
so after
after a minute or two um
after i could get her calm down a little
bit after her name
said her name was
jenny anne mafeo
and she said she was on her way to work
and then she said
holy jesus mother of god
don't let me die
[Music]
she said help me
don't let me die help me
[Music]
captain tardio came back to me and said
he couldn't find an elevator that was
harping
so that meant
that firefighters
had to climb
and to the top would be 110 stories
[Applause]
going up
and as
firefighters came in
they came in quietly
this noise from the equipment we carry
but they didn't say a lot
they were
thinking about what lied ahead
[Applause]
and
they thought about
how they would handle it
[Applause]
and i could remember
one lieutenant
coming up to me
uh lieutenant from engine 33
not saying a word
and we looked at each other
wondering
if
each of us was going to be okay
and then i told that lieutenant
as i told many other officers that came
in
i said take your firefighters
go upstairs
as you go up evacuate the building
and then go up to the 70th floor where
you'll regroup
so we could
rescue those that are trapped
the lieutenant
turned around
took us firefighters
and as he turned around
and started to go upstairs
that was the last time i saw my brother
kevin
[Music]
we had a long way to go
but when i was 18 i joined the marine
corps
i remember
in boot camp
it rung back in my head a jingle that we
used to to say when we were marching one
two three four i love the marine corps
and that's what i that popped in my head
when i was climbing the stairs
that old jingle from the marine corps
and boot camp it just came right back it
was amazing because i hadn't thought
about that for my god
over 30 years and it just all came back
to me you know and it helped me get
through get help me climb those stairs
[Music]
the stairways are relatively narrow
but everybody handled themselves very
well
nobody panicked
people were thanking us thanks for doing
a great job
[Music]
and i just said to the guys it's going
to be a tough day
but we're going to get through it
yeah 175 recycle your transponder square
code 1470
united 175 new york
united 175 do you read new york
another 1489 do you read new york
1489 go ahead okay just wanted to make
sure you read new york
hello
do you um see that united 175 anywhere
and do me a favor you see that target
there that 33.5 climbing don't know who
he is we have a hijack we have some
problems over here right now
oh you do
yes i can't get a hold of united 175 at
all right now
i don't know where he went to
all right
okay i'll see if i have one
united 175 new york
mike and i are here yeah we're both
standing here we're looking right at it
so believable
[Music]
i love you bye
i got somebody with me we're fine
bye-bye mike let's go check it out come
on
why
enough for some of the information about
this incident as we look at live
pictures live right center an airplane
crashing into the side of the world
trade center uh this happening uh is as
far as i can it's a place is
[Music]
i'm in the walk-in refrigerator
for a good 15
minutes the door is closed
[Music]
and when i come out of the refrigerator
there's nobody there
there's no kitchen staff there's no
waiters there's just nobody there and
i'm like where's everybody at where you
know where's everybody at
i look into the chef's office and i
notice
the ceiling is cracked there's a crack
in the wall a little bit of water coming
down
and then a guest comes in from the
restaurant and i go to tell him like
you can't be here you know you got to go
back out but i already noticed
he had a crazed look in his
eye and then he's like
just go look
as i'm pushing the door open there's
something caught in the door
i'm looking at again it's a dead animal
so i'm like what is this you know what
is this dead animal doing here and i
look closely
at the arm
and then i get ready to go back in he
said no no no no go outside and look
[Music]
as i look around the courtyard
there's nobody there
i saw burning pieces of metal everywhere
i saw pieces of luggage
i had no idea where they came from
i look around the corner
and then there's there's there's bodies
everywhere
it's as far as i can see it's like just
broken up bodies like
that's all i can see maybe a hundred
bodies broken up into little pieces just
arms and legs and heads and everything
and like um
so like right away i'm freaking out
and then um
some a body can fall out the sky and
land right in front of me just
boom like loud
and just like breaks up when it hits the
ground
and then like a friend of mine i do like
i don't even know where he came from
he's like did you see that kevin did you
see that and it's like
yeah i saw that so now we're trying to
figure out how to get out
[Music]
he was saying and probably correctly so
never get on the elevator
and i remember thinking to myself
there's only two stories i would be
downstairs
before you know it
and i remember pressing the button
thinking myself if the door opens up i'm
getting on it
i press the button the door opens up i
look at it i'm doing come on you're
coming you're coming and he says no and
he goes all the way and i get on the
elevator
and he never made it out
you're listening to live continuous
coverage of a plane crash into the world
trade center this morning this is 10 10
wins wins new york i'm james faraday now
for more on the story 10 10 what's news
man b harris good morning and it is not
a good morning in new york city a major
disaster a plane crash into the world
trade center we're on the line with 10
10 wins account executive joan fleischer
a witness to this
terrible
when i was on the floor with jenny ann
i held her hand
and i yelled
you know numerous times for ems for
emergency services for help nobody was
coming
people were just running by one after
another
and and i i got concerned
so i ran into the bathroom
pulled a clean plastic bag and i filled
it with water
and patted jenny anne down with it
and i could see that jenny ann's clothes
were fused into her skin
while we were on the floor
and when there was no
emergency services help parade coming
um
jenny ann was getting more and more
concerned that she was going to die
she said sacred heart to jesus save me
i don't want to die and i said are you
catholic she said she was
so i said to her let's say the lord's
prayer
our father
who art in heaven
hallowed be thy name
[Music]
thy kingdom come
they would be done on earth
as it is in heaven
give us to stay our daily bread
and forgive us our trespasses
[Music]
as we forgive those who trespass against
us
a need is not a temptation
deliver us from evil
[Music]
he saw the whole thing transpire from
his vantage point on 14th street and
again we're talking about a plane crash
into the world trade center kai what did
you see and what can you see now
uh well i saw the plane come over here
in the other building
[Applause]
[Music]
good
there's no doorway
[Applause]
let's go let's get the out of here
get the out of here
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
and what you're seeing is both towers of
the world trade center on fire
a second plane the size of a passenger
jet
flying into the second tower of the of
the world trade center
and this is a a horrible tragedy
unfolding in new york city
on this what was a bright sunny morning
uh joan obviously the situation has been
growing worse is as you've been watching
it uh how much worse does it appear to
be than initially
[Applause]
oh
stay together
[Music]
[Applause]
we knew at that moment
that our problem just doubled in size
so at that point
we met in the football huddle
[Music]
deputy chief the division chief p hayden
gave us an order
[Music]
half of us
would stay in the north tower
the other half we proceed
to the south tower
[Music]
then it was my turn
it's my turn to go stand in front of
chief hayden
our orders were to go upstairs in the
north tower for search and rescue
and one of the firemen from rescue one
looked up he said we may not live
through today
and we stopped and we thought about what
he said
so you're right we may not and we
stopped and we took the time
to shake each other's hands and wish
each other good luck and it's great
knowing you
and
hope i see you later
and of all those guys i was surrounded
by
i'm the only one that's alive they all
died
[Music]
so i walked over to where my guys were
standing by
guys from line of six
[Music]
and i say to him sorry guys here's the
deal it's a raw deal but this is what we
have to do
we have to go upstairs for search and
rescue in this building
[Music]
and uh
the last thing i told him was
they're trying to kill us boys let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
this is
the repeated radio system got knocked
out when the first plane hit
so chief pipe is having a horrible time
trying to get in touch with anybody on
the upper floor
[Applause]
and that's when he sent me back out
to see if i could grab the repeater
radios
when i stepped out of the building
it was absolute chaos at this time
people
trying to go out climb and trying to
come in
and i look up
and there were hundreds of people
hanging onto the building
[Music]
that's one of the things that sticks
with me every day
[Music]
oh
i can't imagine
[Music]
being in those people's shoes having to
make the choice of either burning to
death or
or
i mean jumping and knowing you're dying
horrible
that's absolutely horrible
poor people
[Music]
[Applause]
when we heard
the crashing sound
it was something that we never heard
before
[Music]
channel
[Applause]
but we knew exactly what it was
every time it happened
uh another life being lost
and it would
rattle us for a couple seconds
but it was
almost motivating us
to push even further
to get to the people that were trapped
[Music]
and i grabbed the pa system
and i made an announcement
[Music]
to wait if you can
we're coming
okay
floor the floor is crumbling
people are tapped at that location
in 1993 we were able to rescue people
off the roof
so having experienced this somewhat
before we
kind of thought that was going to be the
same game plan
and i had so much confidence in the
skill of this pilot flying his
helicopter that i was like if there's
somebody there we're going to be able to
get them off
[Music]
okay
but as we're approaching
you can start to see the size and scope
of this
[Music]
first thing we did was survey the
rooftops of both the north and the south
tower
[Music]
the south tower the amount of smoke that
was billowing up and coming over the
roof
just it was it was out of play
[Music]
aviation 90m
the agency proceed with the message
as people hanging off the windows
proceeded over to the north tower
and there was an opening
by the northwest corner
quarter century
[Music]
and we're taking a look at the northwest
corner
i could make out the little pebbles on
the roof i could see the individual
pebbles that's how close we were
[Music]
we continued circling the towers
if we could have saw somebody there we
would have made a try but
there was nobody up there
[Music]
my
heart just sunk into my stomach
and i'm looking out the window of the
helicopter and i'm seeing
people
i'm seeing mothers i'm seeing fathers
i'm seeing brothers i'm seeing sisters
literally and standing on
the damaged portion
of the building what looked like white
napkins handkerchiefs tablecloths and
they were waving them
to let us know we need assistance we
need assistance can you help us and
there were so many and
there's nothing you can do
but you're witnessing it you're watching
it
and i was reading those facial
expressions and those look in the eyes
and i'm sure they were looking back at
us and they maybe were reading off
facial expressions that
it was bad it was it was very bad
there was nothing he could do for us
i think we actually waved to him
and that was it and then they flew away
so
i told everybody
to call their families
i called john my fiance
my voice shook
and john asked me what was going on and
i said john we're on the 89th floor
we're trapped here
the door to the stairwell is jammed shut
and we can't get out
and i don't know when it'll get fixed i
don't know when what will happen but we
are trapped on the 89th floor
[Music]
i think at that time
when we were making our phone calls
there were probably a lot of people
throughout the world trade center making
similar phone calls calling friends
family loved ones
and communicating
probably fear
anxiety
and love
i think they were all of those emotions
were just running rampant throughout
everybody
[Music]
um
my building got hit by a plane
and right now
i think i'm okay i'm safe now but smoky
i just want to say how much i love you
and uh
i will uh record you when i'm safe
okay mom fine
[Music]
i love you i don't know what's going on
tell the kids
save this message your whole life
i love you i don't know what's going on
here
bye
[Music]
i just want to let you know i love you
when i'm stuck in this building in new
york
there's lots of smoke and you just want
to do but now but i love you always
[Music]
the fbi is looking at reports that there
was a plane hijacking before the crashes
and uh while we don't have any reports
of casualties at this time looking at
the scene
the gaping holes in both towers the
smoke and the flames it is reasonable to
assume that there has been a massive
loss of life in new york city this
morning again this makes the world trade
center bombing about nine years ago
after the second plane hit
a rumble came through the lobby
i can remember
standing up in shock wondering what the
hell is that
i knelt down beside jenny ann again
and
i said to her
you know we we should
try and get out of here if we can
and around the same time pieces of
ceiling were falling
the vapor was getting thicker
you know you could you could see a haze
a gray haze with the kerosene smell was
was developing more
and people were just panicking and
running
and somebody said
help was on the way but we had to walk
for the help
that help was on the opposite side of
the highway
and as i entered the street
um
a fireman approached me
um with a white helmet
always remember him and he just said
jesus he said for sake get out of
here as fast as you can run
and so i asked jenny ann if she could
run and she said she could
and so
our group
ran across the west side highway
[Music]
um
while they were packing jenny anne into
the ambulance
i leaned over and said to her
you're gonna make it
[Music]
you gotta make it now
so
[Music]
[Applause]
is
all i knew
was
i'd been through something horrific
and all i wanted to do was
just go home
have a shower
go back to life
and it was
probably 20 minutes when the phone rang
and it was my sister's husband david
david mccourt
david asked me if i knew where ruth was
ruth was
a little bit over a year and a half
younger than me
we were very close
juliana was ruth's daughter
most loveliest child you could imagine
and
david caught me by surprise
i'm like david
like why don't you know where she
is and he said ron
they were going to california
they were on the plane that left boston
united 175.
[Music]
um i think i got
i think i got down on my knees and i
cried
and i couldn't believe like that
you know
[Music]
i was literally saying they are
the lord's prayer
with this woman
on the ground
of world trade center
you know when my sister's plane hit
[Music]
the most special people were killed
this was my world
never to be the same again
the smoke was so thick it was hard to
see
but i was trying not to think too much
about
the fear
so i would go out and check the door
and it was always jammed
and then the one time i did go out
there was a sudden pounding on the door
[Music]
and i saw these two
white
hands coming through
[Music]
and then the door
opened and the smoke went out
and there were two men standing there in
helmets
with flashlights and an axe
they had come to rescue us
they told us to get out go downstairs
and run
and they went up to rescue more people
and i also learned that they did not
survive
[Music]
they were such
good brave souls that i do call them
angels because i think that they were
and they were doing
everything they could that day to
make sure that people got out of the
tower
and as i said they went up
when they should have gone down to save
themselves but they didn't
they went up
and put themselves back in harm's way
just to save other people so i do think
they were angels
they were true heroes
[Music]
every firefighter and every first
responder knew this was dangerous
[Music]
they saw the smoke
and the flames coming from the top of
the building
but they also knew
that people were in their greatest
moment of need
and they made a personal decision
to go into the building
to rescue lives
[Music]
[Applause]
but in the lobby of the north tower
we had our fire department chaplain
father michael judge
[Applause]
and i could see his lips moving
because he was praying
it was
almost like there's something bad about
to happen
[Music]
this is as close as we can get to the
base of the world trade center you can
see the firemen assembled here the
police officers fbi agents and you can
see the two towers
a huge explosion outraining debris
every cell in my body said get out of
here
and he's telling me to cut his leg off
oh my god
nobody is coming
to save us
we have to get out of this building on
our own
there is still one more aircraft
somewhere
i took the phone and i heard mark's
voice
he said mom i just want to tell you i
love you
there are three guys on board who've
taken over the plane and they say they
have a bomb
you believe me don't you mom
[Music]
he was on the radio he was talking to me
and he said
i'm coming for you brother
i'm coming for you
[Music]
you